last night we told you how kombu harris
is tired of working on the border and
how she wants a better portfolio and can
you blame her we just saw the caravan of
migrants marching toward america who
wants to deal with that but have no fear
reverend al is here that's right al
sharpton has taken his bull horn to
washington to tell good old joe to build
back better with kamala in an interview
with the roots sharpton says he will
tell biden he wants to see
kamala be used more effectively are you
kidding me hey how sometimes less is
more here to react joe concha he is the
hill media opinion columnist and kiera
davis is the host of just listen to
yourself podcast and both of them are
good friends kyra i'm going to go to you
first
um everything that the president gives
kamala she fails it so why give her more
maybe she need to back off a little bit
i don't understand why anyone's giving
kamala or not giving camelot anything
isn't she like one of the most powerful
people in the world sure i would be
grossly insulted if my pastor
and my boss met without me to discuss
ways that i could do my job better i
mean what what how insulting and i don't
understand here's what i think lawrence
i think camel has the worst advisors in
the world maybe only parallel by joe
biden how on earth could you think that
that makes you gives you any kind of
position of power to send this grifter
in to negotiate for you
for your job when you're the vice
president of the united states just pick
a job and do it you know she didn't even
do the one she had so but i i don't i'm
with you i don't i can't imagine how
this helps
to have al sharpton marching up to the
white house and boss and joe biden
around so joe i'm always surprised by
this when it comes to kamala because she
was also the first candidate that was
out of the primary i mean the democrat
voters rejected her so i don't
understand why there is a
entire group of people that is pulling
for her to be the face of the democratic
party because we already know we may not
see joe biden on the next next ticket
right
a great point she's supposed to be
playing b and i love how she's called
2020 presidential candidate good point
lawrence she didn't even get into 2020
didn't even get to iowa because she was
polling so poorly but just spitballing
here for a moment should the vice
president show she could do one job well
before giving more jobs in this
situation because 23 percent of
americans approve of the way the crisis
that is a catastrophe is being handled
at the southern border and you'll never
guess who was put in charge of that as
you said before by the way it's not
franco harris it's not neil patrick
harris it's kamala harris and you've
seen it firsthand lawrence and great
reporting down there you've spoken to
border patrol you hear the same thing
we're getting no help from washington
the president and vp do not care yet
here's sharpton saying no give her more
responsibility you know what maybe we
could put her in charge of a crime task
force how's that sound to reverse
skyrocketing violent crime in many
american cities oh that's right she
advocated a bail fund for rioters in
minneapolis one man who got out has
since been charged with murder so i
guess that's out and look she hasn't
done a one-on-one interview with any
major entity in nearly 140 days the vip
the vp here she's completely m.i.a and
that's lol and and and
except it's really not uh because she's
as visible at this point as michael
avenatti these days so yeah the reverend
thinks that she should have more
responsibility uh i don't think so
kyra you know part of the things that
that is the biggest problem is they're
bringing all these consultants in i mean
i can give you free consulting advice
give a damn show up then do your job fix
the issues and then you'll go up in the
polls
right i'm i'm not sure what the end game
was here when they brought campbell to
the white house but i mean at the end of
the day
i wouldn't put this woman in charge of
my grocery shopping let alone any major
issues and i'm trying to imagine what
negotiations al sharpton is making with
the biden administration to to negotiate
on her behalf if you've got to send in a
guy like al sharpton whose job is
literally to sell favoritism it's little
literally to sell favors
that's a
big indication that you're really not
cutting it at your job
i'll just tell you this cure pretty soon
you may not have groceries for her to
pick up because uh
i need my bacon
kieran joe thanks so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else